terrorism austerity refugees war plague
and famine it's all too easy watching
the news to think the world's a bad
place and getting worse in fact that
kind of thinking is built into our
biology our brains are wired from our
days dodging saber-toothed Tigers to pay
attention to anything shocking
surprising or scary in experiments
people will react more if you say cancer
bomb or war than if you use baby smile
or fun bad news is also more dramatic
it's only natural to pay more attention
to an Ebola outbreak that kills tens of
thousands of people than a vaccination
program that saves millions or to a
stock market crash rather than the rally
that follows it we even think that
people who are more pessimistic sound
more clever even if they're wrong but
there's another side to the story
there's now less poverty and disease
than any time in human history we're
rich a healthier safer and longer lived
in our parents we have access to amazing
technology that connects us to everyone
on the planet and all of the world's
knowledge here in Britain millions give
to charity and help out in their
communities and when there's a refugee
crisis we open our hearts and our homes
the good in the world may not always
make for good headlines but there's no
harm in a bit more positive thinking
you